angler we start with a glimmer of hope
for nevada businesses
this morning the state lifted some of
its capacity restrictions imposed by the
coronavirus
most businesses including restaurants
bars and gyms can now operate at 35
percent capacity
it's a small 10 percent bump but it's a
critical step towards a safe reopening
hector mejia is live this afternoon with
the latest details hector good afternoon
hey there and table capacity also
changed today from four to six people
and it's a welcome sign for this
restaurant lola's
a louisiana kitchen where they're hoping
to serve more families for mardi gras or
fat tuesday
the governor's easing of kova 19
restrictions also means
reservations are no longer required
starting today
also no more capacity limit for outdoor
dining as long as there's social
distancing
places of worship retail stores indoor
malls
libraries rec centers have also moved to
50 percent capacity
while covet 19 numbers are not where
they should be the state reports
downward trends the nevada restaurant
association says while this is
encouraging news
restaurants will continue to face
serious challenges until they can reopen
at full capacity
the chef and owner here at lola's agrees
the most exciting part is is that
families of six
can come in so we're no longer
discriminating against larger families
my downtown location is temporarily
closed until we can get
even more than 35 percent
if everything goes well the state will
loosen capacity limits again
in one month's time starting march 15th
capacity is set to go
up to 50 percent for most businesses and
activities and we have a full breakdown
of the timeline
on our website eight news now dot com
reporting near
reporting in summerlin hector mejia
eight news now hector thank you very
much